وبلشان ما يوجه لهيئه الانتخابات التونسيه
من اتهامات بعدم الحياد قال الناطق الرسمي
باسم الهيئه التليل المصري للجزيره ان
الهيئه بمن انا عن التجاذبات السياسيه
التجاذبات اولا وثانيا بالنسبه لعمل
الهيئه في الواقع نحن نعمل تحت ضمانات تحت
ضمنات اولا رقابه المجتمع المدني رقابه
الصحافه رقابه الاعلام رقابه الملاحظين
الدوليين والمحليين نحن تقريبا هناك عرب
ما يتجاوز العرب 4,000 و480 ملاحظ محلي
وتقريبا 830 ملاحظ دولي واكثر من 200
تقريبا صحافه اجنبيه دوليه همم قدمنا كل
الاعتمادات لكل من يطلب ومن يريد الملاحظه
الا من يرفض التعامل مع الهيئه هذا حقه في
نهايه المطار المقاطعه وفي نهايه المطاف
كذلك موقف نخدم كذلك ونعمل تحت رقابه
محكمه اداريه
واضاف الناطق باسم الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في تونس ان قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي عدم ارسال مراقبين للانتخابات
البرلمانيه التي تجري غدا السبت لم يغير
من استراتيجيه الهيئه في اسناد الاعتماد
لمن رغب من المراقبين وفق الشروط
القانونيه
معناها ملاحظين من جميع الدول العالم حتى
من الاتحاد
لم تتغير كل من يطلب اعتماد ويريد
الملاحظه فنحن نمكنه من ذلك تبقى شروط
القانونيه بطبيعه الحال في نهايه المطاف
هو موقف بالنسبه لنا احنا نواصلوا العمل
وموجوده حتى ضمنت اخرى في ملاحظات بتاعه
مجتمع مدني ومحلي